hey a.d what do you think happened in  that third quarter we stopped  no defense can't score  um man that's not this third quarter  every third quarter that we play this  season we come out  slow like the days ago  offensively and defensively  we got to get it together well i i can't  tell you  um  but we had to do a better job and we  scored 12 points in the third quarter  they scored 40.  that's the game right there  you know we got to do a better job  coming out in the third  championship team it's not up right now  um not winning a championship  um the way we're playing  but we got to be better and  we got to care  more  for our wins at home wins in general  um that's  embarrassing